tant public sénat
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat fin février 2012 elle
était 3030 est une femme à avoir
remplacé leurs prothèses mammaires
il faut dire que depuis le scandale à
des prothèses pip et le ministère de la
santé recommande vivement aux trente
mille femmes porteuses de ces fameuses
prothèses de se les faire enlever
vous le savez au sénat une mission
commune d'information travail sur les
dispositifs médicaux implantables autour
de la sénatrice ump de paris chantal
jouanno
cette mission a organisé hier une table
ronde sur la médecine esthétique table
ronde que je vous propose de suivre tout
de suite bonne matinée a tous bien
mesdames messieurs je vous remercie
d'être présent je tiens d'abord à vous
présenter les excuses de notre
présidente chantal jouanno qui était
retenu par des impondérables et le nom
que l'honneur de présider cette table
ronde
mes chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir dans le cadre de
cette table ronde consacrée à la
médecine esthétique
un grand nombre d'experts du sujet et je
resterai soit un chacun d'entre eux de
se présenter au début de son
intervention
nous souhaitons que vous nous éclairer
sur les contours de secteur encore peu
encadré la médecine esthétique les
dysfonctionnements constatés et les
réponses à y apporter les personnes que
nous avons auditionné jusqu'ici ils vont
exploser des positions différentes
quant à la spécificité de la médecine
esthétique certains évoquent sa
consécration en tant que spécialité
médicale à part entière d'autres
souhaitent qu'elle demeure une
composante d'autres spécialités comme la
chirurgie esthétique ou la dermatologie
d'autres encore envisage ce que
j'appellerais une solution intermédiaire
considérer la médecine esthétique comme
un exercice particulier comme
l'allergologie par exemple il sera
intéressant de recueillir votre
sentiment sur ce sujet par ailleurs tant
qu'il n'aura pas été établi de
définition claire de la médecine
esthétique et son chat il restera
difficile de l'encadrer afin de mieux
prévenir
indésirable qui sont associés le décret
en préparation soulève encore des
difficultés en août contrairement à
d'autres spécialités médicales nous
constatons un manque criant de données
scientifiques sur la médecine esthétique
et des effets secondaires aux
complications qui en découlent je vous
invite donc en réponse aux questions de
l'autre à porter nous faire bernard
cazeau à la franchise et à nous faire
des propositions concrètes pour corriger
les dysfonctionnements et les manques
que vous auriez pu déceler
enfin je vous rappelle que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse et au
public
elle fait également l'objet d'un
enregistrement audiovisuel et
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat
êtes vous d'accord d'air pour cette
retransmission pas d'opposition je
laisse maintenant la parole à notre
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs nous remercions d'avoir donc
répondu à notre demande concernant table
ronde peut rester une table ronde à les
tenir on ne la met presque sur la
médecine esthétique
si on peut résumer le terme puisque je
pense que comme l'a dit le président et
il ya des points de vue qui sont
différents alors on va commencer par
définition parce que j'ai toujours à
partir de là qu'après on peut avancer
dans la réflexion
quelle définition d'ennuyer vous de
l'acte de médecine esthétique assistons
à une augmentation du nombre des actes
en france au cours des dernières années
et je complète parce que c'est la même
question
la suite de cette question n'observons
pas une dérive ou constit consistant à
requalifier en médecine esthétique un
certain nombre d'actes pourtant
assimilable à de la chirurgie esthétique
afin de la pouvoir les pratiques et en
cabinet et les soustraire en quelque
sorte à la réglementation applicable à
la chirurgie esthétique qui elle est
bien bien précise et bien drastiques
je donnerai comme exemple hypotonie par
injection de produits poe disant voilà
on va faire déjà une première question
de cela on verra ensuite sur
l'information non pour l'organisation du
débat on va commencer par balle à gauche
ici vous présenter rapidement pour qu'on
puisse bien situé et de quels lieux vous
parle
voilà alors oui si vous appuyez sur le
petit bouton rouge le gros le voilà
c'est bon on allait bien je me
présentais je réponds aux deux premières
questions je me prenne seulement
maintenant à prier les gens vous
répandez comme vous voulez au hainaut
mais ce que vous d'accord donc je le
docteur françois thurman je suis
président du syndicat la fédération
syndicale des médecins esthétiques un
anti âge
donc pour répondre à votre première
question s'agissant la définition moi je
reprendrai celle qu'on avait donné en
2004 lorsque j'avais l'honneur de
présider un colloque au sénat qui
s'intitulait quel avenir pour la
médecine esthétique
donc je reprendrai de cette même
définition parce que je pense pas
qu'elle est qu'elle ait changé c'est
l'ensemble des prescriptions à des actes
visant à prévenir améliorer ou corriger
les aspects esthétiques ou jugés comme
tels par un sujet sain quel que soit son
âge y compris les conséquences du
vieillissement physiologique et ce grâce
à une approche pluridisciplinaire
donc vous voyez qu'on pèse on pèse pas
mal de maux y compris s'ils voulaient
cette approche pluridisciplinaire est à
dire médical et chirurgical
je veux bien répondre à la deuxième
question concernant les dérives
tout d'abord tout d'abord sur le
sur l'augmentation du nombre des actes
pardon qui était la deuxième deuxième
alinéa de la première question
on assiste globalement une croissance à
deux chiffres qui a été beaucoup plus
soutenu dans les années 2005-2010 qui
décroît très légèrement mais qui est
toujours à deux chiffres
apparemment par contre il faut mettre en
parallèle s'ils voulaient la croissance
aussi de l'offre de soin cette demande
bien sûr augmente mais l'offre de soin
augmenter si c'est à dire qu'il ya de
plus en plus de médecins qui font des
actes de médecine esthétique
il n'y a pas que des médecins
esthétiques il ya des chirurgiens et
maxillo-faciale bien sûr les
dermatologues
il y à des zones rurales les ophtalmos
etc donc on voit que l'offre de soins
considérablement augmenté concernant la
deuxième question
moi je pense pas si vous voulez qu'on re
qualifie d actes médicaux
la problématique a toujours été de
qualifier certains actes frontières il y
en a un qui a été requalifiée un acte
chirurgical qui est la lipoaspiration
donc c'est s'est classé aujourd'hui les
actes et en particulier la technique que
vous citez la lipotomie par injection de
produit ni paul is an est une technique
interdite par mes craie interdite pour
tous les praticiens donc qu'on soit
médecin ou chirurgien est interdite par
décret ce qui souligne l'importance si
vous voulez l'intérêt d'une formation
pour tous les médecins concernés alors
bien sûr il faudra graduée cette
formation en fonction de l'origine des
médecins s'ils sont qualifiés en
médecine générale
si son dermatologue ou si son chirurgien
plasticien ils n'auront pas
effectivement les mêmes modules si vous
voulez à suivre
mais il faudra bien sûr que tous aient
une formation soit elle sera dans leur
diplôme initial soit elle fera partie
d'un diplôme universitaire c'est tout
l'intérêt ce que vous soulignez monsieur
le rapporteur
tout cela était et est actuellement si
vous voulez l'objet d'une discussion
dans le nouveau décret dans le nouveau
projet de décret qui fixe les conditions
réalisation de ces actes qui présente
des risques sérieux autres que ceux
relevant de l'article l
6322 c'est-à-dire autres que ceux qui
sont chirurgicaux
nous sommes bien d'accord là-dessus
envers la semaine je dirais sur les
rapports il décrit ensuite pardon on
verra on discutera du décret ensuite on
pas tout mélanger
j'appuie je crois que tu dois éteindre
donc je me présente je suis catherine de
goursac je suis membre du conseil
d'administration de la fme pour la
définition de l'acte médical je pense
que c'est à peu près celui qu'on a
donnée ou sinon c'est ce sont des actes
médicaux permettant de modifier
l'apparence corporelle sans forcément
avoir un but strictement thérapeutique
au sujet de l'augmentation lyn cassady
que mondialement il y avait une
augmentation de 11,2 pour cent d'actes
esthétique dans le monde
on pense qu'en france il y à une
croissance un petit peu inférieur
elle serait de l'ordre de 5 à 8 % dans
les congrès mais internationaux il la
plupart des intervenants ne sont pas des
chirurgiens il ya moins de 50% des
publications et des lectures des
conférences qui sont faites par des
chirurgiens donc la médecine esthétique
à ou la dermatologie esthétique à une
très grande ampleur plus importante que
la chirurgie donc pour moi la médecine
esthétique ne rejette une demande des
patients
ils ne veulent pas forcément passer par
la chirurgie s'ils peuvent passer autres
par d'autres actes plus léger que là que
la chirurgie il le réclame et c'est pour
ça que il y a dans tous nos congrès
énormément de méthode et de validation
de nos techniques qui ont donc enfin
dont on publie tous les effets
secondaires et je pense que il n'ya pas
tant de flou que cent par rapport à tout
ce qui
dans les autres domaines médicaux si
vous voulez bon voilà c'est tout pour
moi pour l'instant
alors moi je suis professeur christian
dubreuil je suis chef de service à lyon
service de chirurgie qui fait un peu de
chirurgie esthétique mais je suis là
parce que je sais moi qui dirige le
diplôme de médecine morphologique et
anti-âge de ce diplôme qui existent en
france qui soit actuellement reconnue
alors pour répondre deux premières
questions sans but thérapeutique peut
être en fait à des gens qui vivent mal
leur visage dire et cetera envie d'être
plus jeune donc au premier degré
effectivement n'est pas malade mais
psychologiquement et des gens qui ont
besoin d'être rassurés sur l'avenir donc
ça rentre quand même on leur 21e siècle
dans une prise en charge thérapeutique
de même qu'une psychothérapie permettre
aux gens de passer un cap difficile
on peut pas passer au delà c'est terminé
maintenant on est dans 21e siècle alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on voit on va
beaucoup en médecine esthétique
premièrement parce que c'est moins cher
deuxièmement il ya moins de risques la
moindre risque
il suffit de regarder les médias quand
on regarde et les complications de la
chirurgie esthétique on voit que ça
est-ce qu'on voit souvent la télévision
des complications de médecine esthétique
on en voit très peu
pourquoi parce qu'il produit utilisé me
sens on en reparlera sont beaucoup moins
dangereux et les actes sont réversibles
à plus ou moins long terme
alors il n'y a pas de dérive pour
requalifier des actrices raid a surgi
statique le dit monsieur turmel on
n'enseigne pas aux débuts de médecine
esthétique morphologiques anti âge des
actes qui ne sont pas autorisés on se
limite à la loi et la lipolyse est vu
tant qu'il aura pas de publications qui
montreront l'innocuité de cette
technique
ce ne sera pas enseigné en faculté de
médecine de lyon
d'autant lydia ory président de la
société française de médecine
morphologique anti âge qui soutient et
le diplôme interuniversitaire de
médecine morphologique en tirage quelle
est la définition de l'acte de médecine
esthétique d'abord cénac de médecine un
acte médical
ensuite c'est un acte de médecine qui
permet sur la demande du patient de lui
permettre une image satisfaisante soit
parce que l'hérédité ne l'a pas aidé
soit parce que deux longues balles à
guînes ne l'ont pas aidé soit parce que
simplement les dégâts du temps qu'ils
avancent nous avons aujourd'hui les
grands progrès technologiques qui ont
permis des techniques de soins moins
invasif légère moins à risque plus
sécuritaire qui aujourd'hui sont
enseignés d'une manière scientifique et
rigoureuse par des universités en france
sous la forme du diplôme de médecine
morphologique anti âge et nous avons
aussi des progrès technologiques qui ont
permis longévité de meilleure qualité et
de plus longue durée
il s'avère que ce qu'on appelait les
fleurs du cimetière qui étaient des
simples tâches dans sur le visage sur le
décolleté sur les mains on les cantons
les avez ça s'appelait des fleurs du
cimetière ton comme ur et dans les dix
ans qui suivent est aujourd'hui quand on
les a trente ou quarante ans on va vivre
40 ans avec est ce que nous avons le
droit aujourd'hui de ne pas permettre
aux gens de se débarrasser d'un an
jeunes du visage de se débarrasser de
taches brunes de se débarrasser d'un
affaissement du visage
est ce qu'on a le nom nous vivons dans
une société de consommation nous vivons
dans une société où les gens travaillent
plus longtemps ils doivent être en forme
et la médecine esthétique ce n'est plus
que l'aspect physique c'est l'aspect
physique mais entraîné par les carences
internes liées au temps qui passe
on a un corps qui produit moins et le
médecin institutions aujourd'hui il ne
peut plus faire qu'un geste technique
doit faire un geste technique
scientifique et sécuritaire donc sous
l'égide d'une d'un encadrement
universitaires mais aussi doit savoir
dépister les carences liées à l'âge et
les compléter
donc la médecine esthétique est un acte
médical qui nécessite aujourd'hui de
s'intéresser à l'aspect physique mais
aussi aux carences enfin est-ce qu'on le
laisse la médecine esthétique cash de la
chirurgie certainement pas depuis que le
diplôme incarner cet interdit versèrent
de métier ses tics existe aujourd'hui
anti âge nous avons tous une charte que
nous signons dans laquelle on atteste qu
on ne fera jamais de chirurgie et
d'ailleurs on ne nous enseigne pas de la
chirurgie esthétique aujourd'hui les
encadrements sont de plus en plus défini
de plus en plus clair et nous savons que
nous allons être enseignée par l'amitié
ses tig parce que nous sommes médecins
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
lorsque nous avons auditionné d'ailleurs
ce sociologue et puis à l'anthropologue
c'est exactement ce type d' approche et
d'entonner obligé de tenir compte
aujourd'hui on continue la vie' de
xavier d'eau donc je suis vice président
du conseil national de l'ordre des
médecins en charge des relations avec
les universités alors ce titre et on
s'est déjà vu à ce titre une quinzaine
de jours
quelle définition donneriez-vous de
l'acte médecine esthétique nous sommes
penchés sur cette définition depuis plus
de dix ans et pour nous il est clair que
la médecine dite esthétique car le mot
n'existe pas ni au sens académique ni au
sens universitaire du terme ce n'est pas
une spécialité
c'est un acte médical à part entière et
qui nécessite une inspection en
interrogatoire un examen clinique
un diagnostic un diagnostic différentiel
est le traitement le plus approprié au
cas qui arrive devant le médecin
donc cette médecine d'ailleurs quand il
y à une erreur ça va devant le
disciplinaires aux consignes nationales
de médecins au même titre que toutes les
autres médecines donc pour nous on est
totalement dans l'exercice de la
médecine et l'acte de médecine
esthétique est avant tout un acte
médical au sens
2 au sens exact du terme alors pour les
dérives requalifier en médecine
esthétique un syndrome d'actes
effectivement on s'est aussi penché sur
cette problématique
pour faire très court les techniques ont
clairement évolué et d'aimer technique
micro invasive et qui sont prenez si
vous vous regarde devant un nez les
journaux féminins
tous les jours toutes les semaines ou de
même dans les émissions de télévision
sont prenez certaines techniques dites
de médecine esthétique et ces médecines
peuvent effectivement être fait beaucoup
plus facilement maintenant dans un
cabinet médical au niveau chirurgicale
je pense pas qu'il y ait une fuite de la
législation ce d'autant qu'on connaît
bien maintenant
l'encadrement les légal aussi bien des
cabinets médicaux que dès l'es2 décrite
2005 concernant l'exercice des
chirurgies call et je ne pense pas qu'il
y ait de dérives de ce côté là par
contre la lipotomie lipolyse bien sûr
sont des actes totalement et
définitivement interdite et ses sorties
de nouveaux cas bullaires merci
rien dans l'auto log bonjour donc je
suis le docteur luc sud movie que je
suis le président du syndicat national
des dermatologues et vénéréologues
plutôt que de revenir et d'essayer de
redéfinir exactement qu'est ce que c'est
que esthétique ça me semble devenir
difficiles il vaut mieux je pense parler
d'acte esthétique médicaux par
opposition à des actes esthétiques
chirurgicaux et c'est beaucoup plus
simple de définir puisque de dessiner de
cette façon là puisque les chirurgiens
définit ce qui est chirurgical et chacun
est dans son métier en effet on trouve
et on a évoqué tout à l'heure des formes
absolument frontières ou à se dire
est-ce que c'est chirurgicale ou pas
chirurgicale et l'arctique de 2005
mon confrère du conseil de l'ordre a
évoqué concernant les actes chirurgicaux
et le lieu d'exercice de ces actes
chirurgicaux définit très bien l'endroit
où on doit faire certains actes
certains actes esthétiques chirurgicaux
mais vous avez aussi pu voir que tout à
l'heure on a évoqué et mes confrères ont
évoqué un tas de choses un tas de
discipline
touché par tout ce qui était médecine
esthétique en fait c'est pour ça qu'il
faut parler de geste d' actes
esthétiques médicaux et non pas une
discipline spécifique puisqu'on retrouve
dans le diplo de morphologie anti âge
certains actes on retrouve dans
certaines disciplines dont dans la
mienne certains actes effectivement de
dermatologie esthétique mais il est bien
qu'il est bien sûr évident que lorsqu'on
parle de nutrition ou d'endocrinologie
je n'ai rien à faire moi en
endocrinologie dans ma spécialité
donc en fait chaque retrouver des actes
médicaux esthétique dans chaque
spécialité et il n'est pas question de
regrouper tout ça dans une seule vocable
une seule spécialité
je pense qu'on retrouvera un tas de
choses et ce n'est pas la médecine
esthétique sont des actes médicaux
ce sont des athlétiques médicaux et avec
des choses que l'on retrouve dans
plusieurs choses que dans plusieurs
spécialités y compris dans certains
diplômes comme le diplôme de médecine
morphologique et anti âge quant aux la
dérive pour la requalification
effectivement il ya des arrêtés il ya un
arrêté récent concernant la lipolyse
vais pas y revenir puisque mes confrères
ils sont je suis le dernier à parler
donc ce n'est pas faire des choses
redondantes ce n'est pas très utile mais
je pense que là effectivement il ya une
législation qui est en place et qui est
qui qui se doit d'ailleurs des impôts
tenue rapide à mon sens lorsqu'on
définit des actes et non pas courir
derrière des choses qui sont déjà
présentes
c'est un peu le même le problème aussi
qu on évoquera certainement tout à
l'heure pour tous qui est
matériovigilance on est un petit peu en
retard on est toujours derrière à la
traîne alors que les choses sont déjà
présentes un grand exemple ils
toucheront un peu plus particulièrement
notamment ses cabines uv par exemple les
cabines uv
on a laissé se développer les cabines iv
on est bien ennuyé maintenant avec
toutes les choses qui apparaissent au
niveau des articles et les cancers de la
peau donc c'est un peu dans cet esprit
là ce niveau du matériel financé au
niveau des actes esthétiques médicaux je
pense qu'il faudrait travailler par
opposition à des actes esthétiques
chirurgicaux et n'ont pas travaillé en
essayant de définir exactement un cadre
exact à une spécialité qui n'est pas
encore défini et puis toi et cesser de
mettre à l'intérieur quelque chose qui
concerne des choses concernant les
médecins par opposition aux chirurgiens
oui moment seule approche son terme de
débat sociétal qui met qui m'intéressent
prodigieusement tu restes quand on parle
de médecine anti-âge dire c'est déjà
tout un programme
sachant que les standards en matière
d'esthétique là comme ailleurs sont
parfaitement variable d'une époque à
l'autre et d'une société à l'autre
donc moi ce qui me gêne un petit peu
c'est que si je sors du champ de
l'activité tout ce qui a été évoqué et
qui relève effectivement d'une véritable
pathologie
pendant tout à venir on a évoqué les
angiomes et que sais-je l'avenir le
débat ne se pose plus ensuite quand ça
relève uniquement de l'aspect esthétique
avait tout le côté subjectif que ça peut
avoir
moi j'y vois quand même une forme de
dérive sociétale sachant quand même que
au passage les standards esthétiques que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
généralement somme initiés et puis quand
on arrive au bout de la démarche est que
s'engage une forme d'activité
on sait où sociologiquement les gens
préférentiellement vont avoir la clé
économiques de l'accès se faisant
d'ailleurs au passage on renforce une
espèce de peur classe qui en même temps
qu'il utilise les soins en question est
bien grande force
les critères de jugement ça me gêne
profondément et j'aimerais savoir si
parmi tous nos interlocuteurs
d'aujourd'hui quelques-uns d'entre eux
se posent véritablement cette question
parce que ça revient un peu au coût de
l'apprenti sorcier quand il ya une
évolution exponentielle
pas tout à fait quand même mais qui
existe réellement honnête qui plus est
en droit de se demander si l'offre ne
nuit pas au passage la demande sur la
base des critères que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
donc au dollar encore une fois mon
propos c'est au delà de tout ce qui
présente sur le plan de la pathologie
quelque chose d'avéré ou à venir après
tout le reste
excusez moi mais je trouve que
discussions là qui est qui est très très
très très très difficile à assumer merci
qui veut répondre un collègue me
heureusement et au conseil national
justement on s'est posé la question dès
2003 une demande évidente du public des
affaires qui passait en disciplinaire
des affaires qui n'était pas d'actes non
déclarée puisque hors nomenclature et la
réflexion qu'on s'est fait ya dix ans on
ne peut plus laisser errer cette
population qui demandent des soins dits
esthétique dans l'insécurité totale et à
l'envers souvent des médecins qui
étaient borderline un petit peu
charlatans c'est là où on s'est dit
notre devoir d' ordre des médecins est
d'amener la sécurité des patients et la
qualité des soins et c'est qu'à ce
moment là on a réuni au conseil national
de l'ordre des médecins
les différents partenaires qui
s'occupait déjà d'esthétique il ya eu
des dermatologues les eurl les médecins
dit esthétique
qui est qui était déjà sur le sueur dans
dans ses actes et on leur a demandé de
d'effectuer un des référentiels et un
enseignement national qui permette de
valider au moins certaines de ces
techniques mais notre souci nous c'est
pas de cesser de répondre à part la
sécurité et la qualité des soins oui
alors je vais pas très bien vous n'êtes
pas compris qui vous étiez monsieur non
mais je peux pas comme si ouvert le
public excusez moi mais je ne vous
connaissais pas pardon mais
effectivement comme vous le soulignez
monsieur le sénateur c'est tout c'est un
fait sociétal c'est un fait sociétal
puisque dès 2004 on avait je sais pas si
vous avez pu retrouver les actes du
colloque qui avaient été enregistrées
ici mais on avait fait on avait fait 1-1
colloque sur quel avenir pour la
médecine esthétique présidait au co
présidée par le sénateur fouché le
député pierre morange et moi j'avais
l'honneur de présider ce colloque donc
comme c'est un fait sociétal et comme le
souligne le sénateur c'est aussi quelque
chose d'existant ciel se pacsent iodé
semencière l'esthétique mais moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec xavier d'eau
pour dire qu'on peut pas laisser les
gens qui sont en demande et la demande
est croissante si vous voulez à aller
vers n'importe quel type de
professionnels il ya des professionnels
médecins il est possible nos médecins et
aujourd'hui on nous parlera tout à
l'heure il ya une dérive
s'il ya dérive c'est plutôt si vous les
verts vers les esthéticiennes qui
pratiquent des actes médicaux
larry est réellement dérive trouvait pas
assez ce qu'elle dit permettez nous de
dire le contraire
donc nous on estime que c'est ce qu'elle
craint lorsqu'elle pratique de la
lumière pulsée c'est un acte médical
c'est pas un est normalement dévolu aux
esthéticiennes
bon je sais quel on vous dira le
contraire mais ça c'est pour des raisons
économiques
ta voilà ce que je voulais dire
simplement pour répondre aux sénateurs
esthéticienne parce que c'est important
de savoir que la lampe que nous croyons
tous être qu'une lumière simple c'est
aussi grave est aussi dangereux qu'un
laser
ça fait des trous ça enlève la couleur
et les pour faire ce qu'ils aient une
lampe il faut d'abord faire un
diagnostic faire un diagnostic entre les
tâches que nous voyons est un cancer est
lui qui débute
il faut savoir aussi qu'on reconnaît
canton une peau brûlée savoir la traiter
il faut aussi avoir une assurance qui
protège nos patients si nous avons eu un
aléa médicale donc les esthéticiennes ne
sont pas au courant de tous les dangers
je pense qu'elles sont de bonne foi
elles ont seulement été influencée par
des fabricants sans savoir la portée de
tous ces actes là et d'ailleurs il y à
il ya une jurisprudence qui a interdit
aux esthéticiennes l'utilisation de la
lumière pulsée a juste revenir la
question de départ qui était posée pour
ce faire la différence entre le le
pathologique et le non pathologique
c'est extrêmement difficile en fait
entre le pathologique et non
pathologiques y compris au niveau
cérébral lorsqu'elle ne demandent qu est
trop forte en esthétique
donc il ya le pathologique et non
pathologique le vieillissement de la
peau c'est un phénomène pathologique
aussi puisque ça peut être lié à des
cancers de la peau lorsqu'on visite dans
sa peau vieillit on peut avoir des
cancers de la peau y en a aussi des
rides ou sont deux choses qui sont à la
fois intimement liés dans le
pathologique lorsqu'on parle de
l'esthétique est ce que la de traitement
de la ménopause c'est pas aussi de
l'esthétique médicale endocriniennes à
ce moment là donc parce qu'on est un
train effectivement d'améliorer la
qualité de vie des gens après tout le
rôle d'un médecin c'est d'aider les gens
à mieux vivre
mais pas n'importe comment avec la
sécurité suis tout à fait d'accord voilà
le fond du problème et la sécurité la
validation de certains actes et nous
avons des instances comme la haute
autorité de santé qui sont tout à fait
capable de valider des actrices y penser
enfin notre notre mission est là les
lier aux dispositifs médicaux et elle
fait suite au pipeau pipeau pipeau
prothèses pip est donc où il y avait
déjà la haute autorité de santé où il y
avait déjà des conseils de l'ordre où il
y avait déjà ce peut-être un problème de
moyens
donc c deja et c'est notre mission elle
est basée sur la sécurité sur la
sécurité du patient et dans l'espace
quand je vous pose la question
pour y répondre la sécurité du patient
donc la sécurité ça vient pas comme ça
en dix ans il y en a qui sont c'est
plutôt dans telle spécialité ça sera
plutôt un tel ordre ici et là et il n'y
a aucune règle c'est titienne d'un côté
c'est le nom les midis les médecins de
l'autre les chirurgiens dentistes
convient noir tout à l'heure qui
revendique aussi bref
notre mission consiste à mettre en
exergue sous je vous demande de série un
peu les questions
les capacités requises les formations et
après on verra dans le détail mais au
départ quand on commence une profession
on est formés à la profession et on est
fort mais la profession généralement et
on est formés aux spécialités que l'on
peut mettre à mettre en oeuvre dans
lequel sa profession
donc ce que je voudrais savoir c'est
quelle condition de formation
souhaiteriez voir appliquer aux
professionnels pratiquant des actes de
médecine esthétique véritablement seriez
vous favorable à la généralisation du
combo y en avait un à lyon mais seriez
vous favorable à la généralisation d'un
diplôme interuniversitaire de médecine
morphologique et anti âge
excuse-moi bon j'ai ce mot mais qui me
plaît pas tellement mais bon c'est comme
ça
la médecine esthétique at elle vocation
à s'imposer comme une spécialité
médicale à part entière ou doit-elle
composé être une composante vous avez
dit tout à l'heure vous avez anticipée
d'une autre spécialité chirurgie
esthétique hématologie et quid de
l'information requise pour les
personnels non médecin à qui le médecin
des dégrés d'exécution de certains actes
de médecine esthétique injections
épilation etc voilà dans ce cadre-là
chatelier pour me donner des réponses
bien donc la bresse-hohneck ce moment
c'est répondre puisque actuellement
certaines vous l'avez situe sit in sur
le reporter effectivement un seul des u
interuniversitaire de médecine
morphologique et anti âge à l'anti âge
parce qu'on a pris le monde les antennes
jing mondiale savaria dira quelque part
c'est comme ça et donc de nous pensons
qu'il faut qu'il faut pas multiplier les
diplômes il faut qu'ils aient un diplôme
de médecine morphologique anti âge qui
soit inter-universitaire donc nous avons
été reçus par le doyen tillier au
ministère nous a dit continuer dans ce
début ma condition que d'impliquer
davantage de facultés effectivement
s'aperçut que le sud ouest s'était pas
s'impliquer strasbourg n'est pas
impliqué ça j'en fais mon affaire si
vous voulez on aura donc parce qu'elle
sait très difficile d'enseigner dans une
ville comme lyon on n'a pas tous les
intervenants
faut avoir des intervenants qui viennent
de la france entière c'est pourquoi lyon
pourquoi pas paris ça n'a aucune
importance à mon avis un seul diplôme et
un numerus clausus actuellement il ya 85
étudiants en première année à présent
qu'un après un examen d'entrée donc on
ne font pas plus de 85 étudiants par an
deuxièmement bas comme je le pensais
notre ami dermatologue je pense c'est
une composante de la médecine
il faut d'abord tout apprendre à faire
des diagnostics on injecte pas n'importe
quoi n'importe où il faut faire un
diagnostic et ensuite on fait un
traitement
donc si on a perdu notre habitude de
médecins de faire des diagnostics et
qu'on se comporte comme un technicien
je pense la médecine esthétique tout
sera plus ce que ce que l'on veut
deuxièmement il ya des d'autres
spécialités comme la dermatologie l'orl
mais cette médecine esthétique en partie
devant les actes techniques font partie
de la maquette il ya une maquette dans
chaque desk donc dans chaque bus les
dermatologues les eurl peut être les
ophtalmologues total morgue après
d'injecter d'un toxine botulinique pour
certaines pathologies de la paupière
donc dans le death que les gens soient
formés pour ceux qui n'ont pas de desk
donc on a créé ce des é u où
interviennent des tas de deux
professeurs d'université pour leur donne
effectivement ce que disait monsieur
d'eau la qualité la sécurité
apprendre à se laver les mains ça
commence par ça apprendre savez les
mains apprendre à faire un diagnostic
connaître les conséquences médico légal
d'un geste connaître la loi kouchner 7
etc etc
j'en passe donc sous les c'est quand
même des huées il ya 200 heures
d'enseignement en 200 heures ont fait
pas que des injections les injections
ces quelques heures le reste c'est
d'endocrinologie c'est des antioxydants
c'est ça c'est à dire apprendre
il ya des dissections bien sûr il ya
huit heures de dissection de la face on
s'offre des artères et les veines qui
dans la maquette à 8h de dissection dans
les autres spécialités problement très
peu même les spécialités chirurgicales
donc ton sûr j'ai moi même je le sais
donc sous les il est important qu'une
formation un encadrement médical pour
que les patients qui sont très
demandeurs prendre la qualité la
sécurité le professionnalisme très bien
alors monsieur
on a prononcé on a on a prononcé tout à
l'heure le mode desk je pense que compte
tenu de l'information actuellement de
haut niveau de l'internât réparé
spécialité et avec l'existence de desk
il faudrait non pas que ce soit un
diplôme inter-universitaire qui
n'offrent aucune garantie de quotas
mehenni de contrôle tout à fait de
qualité entre différentes universités
qui font l'enseignement c'est de faire
un diplôme national équivalent à un desk
et ce diplôme national équivalent à un
desk permettra effectivement d'avoir une
qualité de l'enseignement puisque
l'enseignement sera faite de manière
uniforme à l'échelle nationale est la
deuxième source de cette qualité dans
cet enseignement sera aussi supporté par
un quota de la médaille c'est quoi c'est
un diplôme et un diplôme de en fait qui
peut se trouver à l'intérieur de
l'internât et que vous donne une
compétence dans notre internat dsk de
sct d'études spéciales complémentaires
les tous les ans un configurateur
c'est pas une spécialité ça vous donne
une compétence par exemple c'est une
compétence voilà d'accord là je
comprends voix l'appareil par exemple à
titre d'exemple embêtant c'est non
spécialité voilà tout le monde des
spécialistes maintenant y compris la
médecine générale 1 donc par exemple au
sein de la médecine générale vous avez
vous avez un desk de d'infection eux qui
vous permet d'avoir une compétence en
infectiologie et on l'a on alors
excusez-moi monsieur quand même organisé
un peu porté sur moi plus il regrette
parce qu'il faut que nous nous
comprenions bien sûr avait déjà compris
donc d'un côté un diplôme
interuniversitaire sur de l'autre côté
une compétence qui est inquiétant reste
libre et ça passe quand même parce qu'on
va ça pose pas de problème arbitre ça
pose pas de problème alors en 3d de la
colle conseil de l'ordre oui alors
quelques jours la salle lorsqu'on a
voulu
effectivement la sécurité la qualité
réunit toutes les les médecins qui
s'occupent et d'esthétique la seule voie
possible était le diy du diplôme
interuniversitaire nous leur avons
demandé de nous avons reconnu d'ailleurs
ce titre au droit au titre au niveau du
conseil national d'or des médecins c'est
à dire que les médecins qui ont effectué
cette formation de deux ans ont le droit
d'apposer sur leurs plaques et
ordonnances des é u de médecine
morphologie anti âge la deuxième chose
et on l'a on s'est revus assez
fréquemment pour conforter d'une part
leur maquette d'enseignement on sait que
dans cette maquette il y avait quelques
faiblesses du nouveau au niveau de
l'apprentissage des actes techniques car
il faut que ça prenne aussi
et d'autre part nous leur avons demandé
à plusieurs reprises d'élargir leur
socle universitaire car la formation
c'est pas ce ne sont pas des syndicats
ce ne sont pas des collèges c'est
l'université en france qui est chargée
de la formation et seule l'université
il est ici il s'avère qu'effectivement
si on veut donner une pleine ampleur à
ceux des yeux il faudrait à notre sens
qu'il se transforme en desk desk c'est
une spécificité d'exercice c'est à dire
que le médecin n'abandonne pas son coeur
de métier qui peut-être la dermatologie
la médecine générale tout le monde et
spécialiste la rhumatologie mais va vers
une spécifité l'exercice il faut surtout
pas qu'ils en kaki qu'il qu'il oublie
son coeur de métier la médecine
esthétique ne doit en aucun cas
s'exercer à part entière elle ce n'est
qu'une composante d'un exercice
c'est à dire le fait d'être médecin
dermatologue ne suffit pas sauf s'il
faut avoir des noms n'ont pas tout à
fait d'accord dans le corps de métier
dans l'art ancien métier dermatologue
il y à la dermatologie esthétique par
contre dans ce desk est beaucoup plus
larges comme j'ai dit au tout départ de
mon intervention
il ya effectivement d'autres choses qui
ne concerne pas la dermatologie et si
l'on conçoit ce desk il faudra si le
dermatologue veut par exemple faire la
nutrition pourquoi pas qu'il passe à ce
moment là le module en clair les rides
pour faire les rides il est compétent il
est s'est inscrit dans son référentiel
métier le dermatologue
mais par contre préfèrent de la
nutrition il ne l'est pas il ne l'est
pas donc il faudra qu'il passe un
contenu très sûr esthétique c'est quoi
où il a visité par exemple par exemple
par exemple
par exemple par exemple pendant la can
est une question centrale est une
pathologie au format c'est pas très très
bon exemple peut-être mais bon ça sent
dans ce dans ce desk excessivement
beaucoup plus large que qu'effectivement
juste le traitement des rides se classe
aussi le désir est unanime entre vous si
ça ne l'est sujet entre monsieur ça
laisse pas voilà entre le jeu du droit
et monsieur sublime hovik pour la toute
petite histoire le ministère de la santé
effectivement évolué vers la voie du
desk le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur pour l'instant n'a pas bien
compris
ou du moins toujours un petit temps de
retard dans ce domaine là et pour le
conte conforte le déut mais à terme
effectivement il apparaît qu'au bout de
cinq six ans maintenant d'existence du
déchu
il est clair qu'on veut aboutir au dess
et ça ferait une plate forme commune à
toutes les spécialités existantes et ça
ne marginalise rep à la médecine dite
esthétique dans un petit coin d'exercice
un petit peu des viandes
pourquoi parce qu'on serait
effectivement dans une médecine de la
prévention du bien vieillir mais aussi
bien dans la nutrition dans le haut
niveau intellectuel au niveau
cardiovasculaire au niveau de la
rhumatologie au niveau de la sexologie
tous les domaines sont concernés
monsieur madame on rit aussi oui alors
moi je voudrais apporter quelques petits
détails donc en 2004 le médecin
esthétique n'existait nulle part sauf
dans des compagnonnages privé sinon ceux
des élus n'auraient pas fait serait pas
né donc ça n'existait nulle part
ce diplôme interuniversitaire aînés et
aujourd'hui il n'est pas qu'à lyon il
enseigne à lyon mais il détend de
montpellier il dépend de paris il dépend
de pointe à pitre
il dépend de lyon donc il est il a
élargi son socle universitaire et petit
à petit les chirurgiens les
dermatologues ont rajouté dans leur desk
des journées de médecine esthétique ce
qui est très bien mais le problème n'est
pas de savoir si ça ou ils savent pas la
médecine esthétique c'est qu'une nous
c'est une nouvelle médecine qu'il faut
apprendre parce que il y as pas
seulement le geste pas seulement
l'évolution scientifique mais aussi le
diagnostic internes des carences
alors ceux des u nous avons parlé au
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la santé et le desk les gêne parce
que il faut 4 semestre
il faut dans des services hospitaliers
et ça c'est un peu difficile à trouver
la médecine esthétique n'existe pas à
l'hôpital aujourd'hui dont ils ont été
pour plus tôt et en est que ceux des u a
rempli pour eux quatre conditions que je
vous précise pour eux il a permis de
prévenir les complications les plus
fréquentes c'est à dire les infections
puisque le professeur cohen cuisiniste
en scène la sepsie l'hygiène et a pris
en charge le référentiel médecin cabinet
environnement médical
tout ça est à votre disposition il a
permis de connaître la topographie des
actes à réaliser et à ne pas dépasser
grâce à nos anatomiste des professeurs
du breuil professeur texte etc
il a permis de préciser l'évolution
scientifique des techniques de médecine
esthétique de dépistage de diagnostic
grâce à la trentaine de professeurs
universitaires qui dirige cet
enseignement qui est dirigée que par les
professeurs universitaires sauf que ont
fait appel aux médecins libéraux pour la
bêtise c'est qu'il n'est pas trop connu
encore dans les hôpitaux
et ceci a fait qu' il a permis aussi de
préciser les diagnostics différentiels
entre le véritable besoin est le
fantasme du patient des psychothérapies
l'après permis de préciser les règles
déontologiques et les règles légales un
consentement éclairé de faire incarner
avec le traçage de tout ce qu'on veut
donc ce délit est en est qui la remplit
beaucoup de ses fonctions il a pensé que
rajouter encore trois ou quatre autres
villes le fortifierait c'est ce qu'on va
faire et que pour lui le déut nationale
serait suffisant bien sûr que si on va
vers un desk c'est extraordinaire le
seul problème c'est la difficulté de
réalisation
parce que parce que dans les hôpitaux il
n'y a pas quatre semaines de stage
pratique alors on a proposé que ça soit
fait par des des centres libéraux on a
proposé ça bien sûr ministère il ya
quelques jours
il reste quand même pour le moment
dirigés vers un deuil national où il y
aurait quatre autres villes de plus en
plus des quatre villes existantes
et puis et puis voilà où on en est donc
je veux dire que le déut inter
universitaire est assez fort il élargit
sur son socle universitaire il comporte
une trentaine dont trentaine de
professeurs agrégés
c'est quand même quelque chose de solide
il ya près de 600 médecins qui sont
sortis de là
et qui ne font aucun sinistre le conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins peu le
préciser donc je veux dire ça amélioré
énormément la sécurité des patients et
la connaissance scientifique des
médecins maintenant allez vers l'inde
est pourquoi pas le problème la
difficulté pratique et peut-être faire
un deuil national actuellement
rapidement et puis après évolué vers
l'inde est pourquoi pas oui moi je suis
je suis tout à fait favorable va pas
mois par mois uniquement un desk aussi
dans la mesure où ces housses et une
formation si vous voulez qui permet
effectivement comme le disait xavier
d'eau de permettre à toutes les
spécialités si vous voulez d'avoir une
composante esthétique et ne pas avoir d
exercice exclusif
il est clair on ne s'oriente pas
effectivement vers la havane spécialité
à part entière et à la très peu qui
souhaite qu'on conçoit une spécialité à
part entière donc le seul diplôme
aujourd'hui si vous voulez hormis hormis
la qualité du débit actuel parce qu'il
faut savoir quand même que c'est la
troisième version du 10 du deal en 2002
il ya eu un premier né un 1er une
première tentative de diplômes
universitaires
ensuite il ya une autre tentative à
paris sac et maintenant il ya ce
diplomate air universitaire qui a obtenu
si vous voulez et ses lettres de
noblesse avec la le droit au titre du
conseil national de l'ordre
mais on sent bien que ceux des yeux même
s'il a beaucoup de qualités il ya
quelques il a quelques petits défauts
aucun mot niveau de la pratique les
étudiants nous le dise donc c'est pas
évident d'organiser une pratique pour 85
élèves dans des conditions optimales
et comme il ya quand même un certain
nombre d'actes techniques
d'apprentissage c'est quand même ça qui
est important si vous voulez à tout le
reste ça s'apprend dans les livres mais
les actes techniques on les apprend dans
les services où effectivement pourquoi
pas dans les cabinets médicaux
donc moi effet je pense que l'évolution
logique après peut-être deux ou trois
ans encore pour permettre des cluses et
aussi les diplômés parce que dans le
projet de décret vous avez vu qu'à une
commission il prend une commission
d'habilitation de validation des acquis
pour permettre à ceux qui n'ont pas
l'enseignement universitaire et qui ont
l'expérience et qui font ça depuis 20
ans moins de trois heures voilà où ou
trois ans effectivement
donc avec deux ans de pratique voilà
avec une date de forclusion qui pourra
qu'il faudra peut-être projet parce que
ça semble peut-être un peu court
donc on voit bien l'évolution donc
profite pour pour terminer
personnellement moi je suis plutôt
favorable au desk aussi d'accord
monsieur mirassou la question que je me
pose vous écoute sommes toutes et tous
et pourquoi si ces sujets et capitale y
at il une telle distorsion entre
l'accessibilité par le biais d'un
diplôme universitaire aime tant le vide
et scélérat au niveau hospitalier alors
que à toute logique si ça relève d'une
problématique santé publique est bien
l'un devrait marcher avait l'autre et
inversement
parce que j'ai bien compris quand même
que faute de vacuité sur le plan
spitalier on a évoqué l'éventualité où
ça se ferait d'un système libéral et là
ça renforce mon positionnement initial
qui consiste à dire qu'en tout état de
cause sociologique comment ces pratiques
seront préférentiellement dédiés à des
tranches et pas à d'autres
qu'est ce que vous avez observé un haut
niveau aux sessions tout à fait au
niveau hospitalier la grande angoisse
des formateurs universitaires en
médecine générale et la disparition d'un
certain potentiel de médecins exerçant
en médecine générale vers le côté
esthétique
je pense que c'est un faux problème
c'est un problème de toutes façons ces
gens là serait parti aurait voulu faire
de la médecine esthétique ça ne changera
rien au problème et c'est un petit peu
cette angoisse là entre le puy ce qu'on
manque actuellement même de généralistes
puisqu'on est un peu en pin gris cesser
la fuite est reversé versé vers cette
compétence
je pense que l'encadrement tout au
contraire permettra de réguler et de
réguler et d'avoir une sécurité pour les
patients l'organisme l'organisation de
stages sous le contrôle qu'ils soient
dans le privé est sous contrôle
universitaire est beaucoup plus grand
que deux stages sauvage et que de
formation organisés par l'industrie
pharmaceutique
je pense que leur la garantie
universitaire la garantie universitaire
est un gage de caution pour
médecine française je pense qu'il faut
continuer sur cette voie là là il est
indéniable que ce que nous a dit tout à
l'heure je dubreuil l'autre bon pour
nous ce qui est important c'est que ce
soit fait dans un cadre habituel et
légal absolument on veut pas autre chose
en cabinet ou d où des écoles de francs
soit le cadre le cadre sécuritaire en
france de la matinée bien et bien
l'université mal et dans chaque ville a
bordeaux on a fait la dissection à un
montpellier on a fait l'endocrine aux
halles à lyon on a fait une l'anatolie à
paris on a fait l'hygiène et la sepsie
mais c'était très fatigant de faire cinq
voyages
donc on a décidé de faire pendant des
années on a fait à paris 13eme
maintenant pendant des années ont fait à
lyon et on repartage nouveau entre lyon
et paris et peut-être strasbourg mais ça
nous allons savoir dans les mois qui
viennent donc on en revient on ne
revient tout à l'heure on n'est plus à
une espèce de chose d'absence de
contrôle du nombre de former avec le
diplôme mais le diplôme
interuniversitaire en fait ne permet pas
de contrôle des entrées des sorties
c'est tout le fond du problème nous
avons en france une médecine au niveau
de toutes les spécialités qui est
contrôlé il ya un certain de
dermatologues qui sortent par le diplôme
chirurgien qui sortent par le diplôme
saute d'endocrinologues qui sort par le
diplôme formation de l'internât il n'y a
aucune raison que c'est que cette
spécialité qu'on l'appellera comme on
veut ne ne se soumettent pas aux mêmes
exigences c'est normal madame ne semble
pas tout à fait d'accord
aujourd'hui ministériel plus tard il ya
une loi nous devons tous les ans donner
la liste de ceux qui ont réussi et de
ceux qui ont été inclus dans le
probatoire clé une correction
automatique par ordinateur donc ça fait
sept ans que nous existons nous n'avons
pas dépasser une seule fois le quota
autorisé par le conseil de l'ordre
je vois pas pourquoi ça changerait on a
tu aurais pas que ce soit une compétence
à un diplôme existants bien sûr ou alors
si on n'a pas du tout déplore sont des
généralistes faire un diplôme d huez
universitaire pourquoi pas je suis je
suis d'accord là dessus
tu prenais gerland ce pas le débat je ne
fais une conclusion répondre à monsieur
sénateurs sur le fait que les
informations soient complémentaires
dirait privé
actuellement il ya beaucoup trop
d'internât beaucoup trop d'interdits
pardon c'est interne à lyon va les
former en clinique en orthopédie la
médecine c'est du compagnonnage coup
festive au compagnonnage à l'hôpital ou
en privé la formation est la même donc
c'est très important ça sous l'égide de
l'université qui donne le terrain de
stage et dont ce n'est pas bon je
voulais jouer dira la même chose que
monsieur dubreuil aujourd'hui il est
très clair que quand il n'y a pas
suffisamment de postes d'internât là il
ya beaucoup de jeunes médecins en fin de
stage qui font leur stage interne est
dans les cabinets médicaux et personne
n'y voit à redire
je rassure et monsieur monsieur le
sénateur on va pas vers une médecine
esthétique à deux vitesses
on avait fait on avait fait des
statistiques en 2004 lors du colloque
93% de la population de tout médecin de
médecins esthétiques c'est la tranche
moyenne seulement 7 % de notre
patientèle et dans la classe autres dit
entre guillemets riches
donc voyez c'est quand même pas
l'apanage des médecins esthétiques
ceci étant c'est de l'esthétique donc
c'est pas assez existentielle c'est pas
c'est pas essentiel mais sachez que ont
fait pas de médecine à deux vitesses
maintenant effectivement on prend pas
non plus
les cartes vitale c'est pas remboursés
par l'assurance maladie
alors là peut se pose effectivement le
problème du déconventionnement des
médecins qui font l'esthétique
je pose la question est-ce qu'il faut
que les médecins qui font que de
l'esthétique soit déconventionner non
mais je pose la question j'ai dis pas
qu'il faut qu'il le faut ce qu'il faut
savoir quand même qu'on avait évalué en
2015 et de la fraude la fraude à la
sécurité sociale
la fraude à la sécurité sociale pour les
actes de médecine esthétique
je n'étais pas non mais qui n'aurait pas
dû être remboursés
nous ne sommes pas intéressés par les
histoires de gouvernement est là c'est
assez et de finance plan dont
l'intéressé mais pas de guitare 17 décès
moins ça de côté mes parents je veux
c'est des choses claires comme j'ai à
peu près là jusqu'à maintenant
et puis bon je vous vois qu'ils soient
dans la règle de la pratique médicale
je voudrais rassurer monsieur parce que
ce diplôme interuniversitaire a permis
aux enseignants qui sont des preuves
sera agrégé chef de service de nous
ouvrir des ailes
par exemple en gérontologie nous avons
ouvert un protocole actuellement de soin
d alzheimer en réparant leur visage
cédant leur donnant une jeunesse on a
pensé que comme ces gens ont regardé la
connaissance la mémoire antérograde et
non pas là la rétrogration pas là la
récente en retrouvant leur visage
rajeuni
est-ce qu'ils ne vont pas être moins
dans la crainte mois dans la peur de
revoir leurs visages dans le miroir dont
je veux dire que au contraire ça à
banaliser cette médecine
ça l'a fait rentrer de plus en plus dans
la tête de nos professeurs agrégés qui
les utilisent aujourd'hui dans leur
pathologie
là on va parler d'un problème c'est la
formation requise pour les personnels
non médecin
alors donc c'est un problème là on
aborde alors qu' on dirait que je vous
demande être assez bref quand même parce
que mais pas tout le monde pas toujours
les mêmes qui parlent
donc les placer nos médecins à qui le
médecin oui j'ai pris là j'ai dit à
reconsidérer faire attention à qui le
médecin degré d la grée l'exécution de
certains actes de médecine esthétique ni
injection l'épilation et c'est là c'est
ici elle marche ça y est voilà mesdames
là il faut savoir que la plupart de nos
assurances médicales réclament que nos
assistantes soit fasse partie du
personnel de santé donc ou des
infirmières ou des kinés ou des aides
soignantes donc qu'ils aient une
formation de santé ça c'est la première
chose d'autre part moi j'ai eu un petit
retour du conseil de l'ordre qui m'a
demandé que mon personnage et une
assistante qui m'a demandé qu'elle soit
infirmières donc j'ai une assistante
infirmière
mon assistante infirmière j'ai voulu la
faire formé au début de lasers et là
j'ai eu un petit problème c'est que
ledit de lasers pour les assistantes
n'est autorisée cognac aux infirmières
employés par des dermato et donc je
n'avais pas le droit de faire former ma
mon infirmière au début de laser il se
trouve que comme ça installé avec une
infirmière avec une d'amato donc c'est
plus facile
il faudrait que ça soit ouvert un peu à
tout le monde et que notre personnel
puisse se former aussi donc de façon
complémentaire dans les gestes de
d'esthétique dans votre nom votre
question il faut bien distinguer la
délégation date et la délégation de
compétence et transfert des compétences
ce sont deux choses complètement
différentes
lorsqu'on lorsqu'un personnel non
médical fait un acte et qu'on a fait une
délégation date il est pleinement
responsable de son acte il est auto ni
s'autonomise dans son acte et donc il
est il est dans un exercice à mon sens
illégal de la médecine actuellement
d'accord maintenant la délégation de
compétence ou le transfert de
compétences on va prendre un exemple
simple le manipulateur radio
le manipulateur radio ils effectuent une
partie de l'acte sous la responsabilité
du radiologue
c'est le radiologue qui interprète qui
sera incriminé s'il ya un problème et
non pas le mien aussi
l'infirmière la famille s'est pas dit
c'est pas tout à fait à l'identique
parce que là l'infirmière à ces actes
propre comme un rôle quand alain rollat
voilà tout à fait mais il n'y a pas il
n'ya jamais il n'y a jamais il n'y a
jamais transfert de l'acte complet c'est
le souci est là c'est à dire c'est de
délégation au complet de l'acte et je
pense que c'est extrêmement dangereux la
déviation complète de l'acte parce que
c'est un exercice illégal de la médecine
c'est l'ouverture à d une profession sou
médical que ce soit à la fois en
esthétique ou dans d'autres d'autres
choses ce sont des expériences qui sont
déjà présentes aux etats-unis où les
ophtalmos ont effectivement créé des
compétences pour des personnels qui sont
non médecins et qui réalise des actes
non plus sous l'autorité de
l'ophtalmologiste mais sous leur propre
autorité et qui maintenant sont
complètement autonome
donc je pense que c'est au niveau de la
sécurité des patients c'est un problème
même si on peut dire que des gens qui
soient correctement formés je pense que
actuellement l'entreprise médicale entre
guillemets si on peut s'appeler
l'entreprise médical permet aux tories
d'avoir des personnels qui travaillent
sous l'autorité et sous la
responsabilité du médecin
je pense qu'il faut en rester là et
qu'il faut pas faire de je pense que le
représentant du conseil de l'ordre il
ira dans le même sous l'autorité du
maître
ça va venir les infirmières qui vont
commun comme en suède mais les pôles
instance alors
dans un tout petit ajout tout à l'heure
on a parlé pour les infirmières et puis
je vais répondre
on a et on est en train de créer qui
était une profession qui sont les
assistantes dermato dont je suis
responsable pour la cette création qui
correspond tout à fait déjà passé et
validé en commission nationale paritaire
qui correspond à une spécificité
dermatologiques la spécifité
dermatologiques c'était à ses assistants
de dermato elles vont travailler ça va
être du personnel qui est une secret
qu'elle va à lever polyvalente
secrétaire médicale elle va aider dans
les actes chirurgicaux elle va aider
dans des actes laser elle va aider dans
l'ensemble de la profession du
dermatologue
donc c'est un petit peu c'est un petit
peu différent un petit peu différente
voilà ce que je voulais ajouter au
niveau c'est à dire comme le magic comme
le radiologue a effectivement un
manipule radio qui travaillent qui est
dans sa spécificité de sa spécialité
donc là on aura un assistant
dermatologue libre à aux autres aux
autres spécialités de créer aussi leurs
propres profils professionnels pour les
aider
je poserai pas la salle
la question d'autoriser ces professions
elles doivent travailler dans
l'environnement immédiat est proche et
avec la présence du médecin responsable
oui je vous poserai pas là 5 parce que
vous y avez répondu
seriez vous favorable à la mise en place
d'un dossier médical du patient ayant
recours à un acte de médecine esthétique
qu'on appelle renner incarner esthétique
comprenant des informations relatives
aux dispositifs du produit utilisé aux
zones concernées etc
oui là je crois qu'il faut le dossier
médical dans l'ouest éthique existe
depuis 2004 le cas mais je pense que au
niveau législatif le dossier médical
s'impose à tous
il ne faut pas marginaliser encore une
fois la médecine esthétique en 10 ans
utilisé un petit dossier à eux médicales
esthétiques non tout patient en france
doit avoir un dossier médical vous allez
voir votre médecin il a un dossier
médical qu'il ouvre à chaque fois soit
soit encore sous forme papier soit sous
forme
l'électronique mais vous avez un dossier
médical sur votre médecin vous allez à
l'hôpital un dossier médical est
normalement le dossier médical personnel
ça fait quand même quinze ans qu'on en
parle devrait à terme être le seul et
unique dossier d'un patient parlons pas
de l'arlésienne
oui oui mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est qu'il est indispensable que le
dossier médical du patient soit
renseigné
quand il va faire des soins à visée
esthétique il faut incarner un dossier
médical chez le médecin mais aussi
remettre aux patients parce qu'il est
chez nous ce qu'on appelle mais nous ne
l'avons pas dans les autres spécialités
il a besoin de nouveaux obstétriciens et
l'accouchement
en ce qui nous concerne c'était pas
c'est parfaitement clair tous les
médecins qui pratiquent de médecine
esthétique
ils sont d'abord médecin donc ils ont
leurs dossiers habituels ont il ya un
interrogatoire un diagnostic tout ça et
ensuite ils ont en plus une traçabilité
de ce qu'ils font le produit le la
nature du laser dont tout ça c'est
marqué dans un petit cahier carnet le
double et sur notre dossier médical
comme d'habitude et le carnet remis aux
patients depuis 2004 donc c'est pas
nouveau ça pour l'a déjà fait de nous
mêmes les sociétés savantes s'y sont
mises d'elle-même
en fait en fait le mouvement ne remet
aux patients et leur entourage tous et
le souci le souci c'est qu'on devrait
remettre deux noms mm ci est bon même
s'il est remis le souci je suis tu as
fait pour ce carnet je suis pas
absolument pas compte mais je veux
exprimer un peu par rapport aux patients
le patient en matière esthétique en
france il a tendance à cacher et à ne
pas ne pas manifester c'est à dire que
même ce qu'on observe à titre pratique
en tant que médecin même le carnet qu'on
a remis lorsqu'on revoit le même passion
la même patiente
il n'a pas forcément où il dit qu'il l'a
égaré ou il ajouté parce qu'il n'a pas
envie que son son conjoint sache qu'il a
fait quelque chose est un petit peu
cette ce souci avec le quart des
patients
c'est un peu ce souci ça c'est vrai un
peu de souci
en fait il peut en avoir heures et puis
le cash si vous vous voyez enfin c'est
parfois parfois disparaître ces
questions il ya des problèmes voilà il
va le ressortir où il va aller dire ce
qu'il va l'aider alors parfois on est
soumis à ce problème là parce qu'il n'a
pas où il lui est hydro me l'a perdue où
il n'a pas voulu etc et on est obligé
avant je devais prendre l'exemple des
produits injectables d'interroger le
médecin antérieures pour savoir quel
type de produit parce que pour le pour
nous par exemple les produits
injectables c'est extrêmement important
avant d'injecter de savoir qu'est ce qui
a été injecté auparavant la deuxième
volet c'est le volet la traçabilité et
la traçabilité est extrêmement
importante et je pense qu'il ya un
effort à faire notamment dans les
produits injectables au niveau de la
traçabilité par l'obligation au niveau
des fabricants du met une étiquette de
traçabilité qui n'est pas forcément
présente de manière adéquate et
suffisante dans certains produits
et ça ça me semble ça ça me semble
extrêmement important cette traçabilité
haut niveau au niveau du patient mais
aussi pour le médecin afin d'avoir
quelque chose qui soit facile d'accès
facile admis rod et y compris dans des
produits qu'ils ont actuellement une à
mêmes comme la toxine botulique
il existe des produits qui ont aidé à
mêmes country music dans lequel il n'y a
pas une étiquette de traçabilité dans
lequel il faut recopier le numéro du lot
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
insuffisant à mon sens pour la
traçabilité les patients en esthétique
sont un peu plus nomades que dans le
reste de la médecine est donc en effet
on a un peu un problème lorsqu'on reçoit
le patient de pouvoir reconstituer tout
son parcours
oui donc je vais insister c'est ce que
dit exact excuser notre collègue bizarre
ou en avoir la possibilité s'il ya des
problèmes toi même questionné le patient
se faisait pas incarner parce que c'est
par où le faire sans son conjoint c'est
évident à mes lui dirai ce que vous
vendre parce que j'ai besoin de savoir
ce qu'il va avoir peur ce fut comme ça
et donc il faut savoir aussi c'est là où
l'interrogatoire intervient faut savoir
aussi bon le mettre en confiance
n'ouvrez pas la traçabilité comme l'a
dit notre collègue dermatologue
on enseigne la médecine faire des
diagnostics et des traitements doute
bonnes conditions
mais la traçabilité en ont discuté tout
à l'heure il ya plus de 100 du produit à
base d'acide hyaluronique
d'où vient-il comment sont-ils constitué
comment sont ils fabriqués et là on peut
pas répondre là dessus et là on aimerait
bien on aimerait bien jusque bon et on
puisse contrôler ça c'est très important
parce qu'on risque d'avoir des accidents
médicaux n'ont pas lié à la technique
médicale
nos produits vous produit injecté et
nous médecins on n'est pas censé savoir
si les prothèses pip les protestants les
chirurgies primum non nocere il faudrait
rien faire pour gagner un bon produit
destiné de type qui choque la musique
choc ce fait vous pouvez pas le prévoir
ça non essentielle c'est que le produit
soit authentifié et de qualité tant que
ce soit pas un produit dérivé
on a quand même battu remet en cause un
produit authentifié greki année diskin
et 110
là il ya une autorité il a quand même
bien la fsa mais l'afssaps l'autorisent
à ce moment là bon ce n'est pas dix sont
autorisés par l'afssaps a comme
l'afssaps sur le sable sécuriser un
certain nombre de médicaments
on s'aperçoit que dix ans après midi que
ça va changer
ces trois ans pour transport cpc en fait
on se consulte cette importance là en
fait on souffre d' en matière de
traçabilité du contrôle
c'est à dire que le contrôle est présent
législation à mon sens est présente
l'histoire des prothèses c'est un
problème effectivement de moyens dans le
contrôle ce qui est arrivé au niveau des
prothèses c'est peut-être n'y a pas
assez de contrôles passés de contrôles
inopinés et si on regarde un peu ce qui
se passe au niveau des états unis et
vous avez cité d'acide hyaluronique il
ya 110 produits mais c'est aussi une
question historique s'il y en a cent dix
en france et que l'acide hyaluronique à
pénétrer le marché américain beaucoup
plus récemment et au niveau des
autorisations dédié il y avait aussi un
protectionnisme présent parce qu'elle
avait d'autres produits qui existait
depuis des années aux états ne faut pas
perdre de vue aussi ce côté là je
défends pas assez ironique qui a
certainement trop d'acide hyaluronique
il ya pourtant une législation comme
vous le dites et pourtant je pense qu'il
n'y a pas suffisamment de contrôles
quand on regarde aux états unis des
moyens qui sont mis en jeu par la fda
pour un contrôle par exemple d acide
hyaluronique français en fabrication
française sont actuellement autorisés
aux états unis les chaînes de
fabrication puisque ces produits sont
fabriqués en france et chaînes de
fabrication sont spécifiques pour les
américains avec un contrôle fait par là
et ce billet qui se déplacent qui
numérote absolument l'ensemble
l'ensemble de la chaîne de fabrication
pour toutes les pièces et qui ne tolère
aucun écart pour ce genre de choses et
nous avons pas ce type de contrôles là
est toute la différence elle est
peut-être présente au niveau de la
malléole en six ans d'autres dix ans
cette spécificité la food and drug et
notamment ils ont refusé les prothèses
pip mais certaines disent certains
disent que c'est pas protectionnisme et
donc c'est pas juste
vous avez raison je pense qu'il est noir
je pense qu'il y avait deux je pense
qu'elles les doigts qu'il en soit il
faut puisque nous avons faire dans un
esprit team ico un produit qui est
certifié européen qui dépasse le cadre
français
c'est le problème donc il faut qu'il y
ait une coordination européenne
c'est à ce titre là que dans un second
temps on l'apsap c'est la haute autorité
la haute autorité d'abord et l'absence
ensuite pourront donner des
certifications du produit ou non à
partir mans où c'est seulement
vérificateur ou notificateur pendant
l'appel qui dit que le produit est bon
alors sans comme vous le dites vous avez
raison de vérifications qu'ils ne soient
pas inopinés et bien évidemment il ya
les dérives et on peut tomber sur des
escrocs ce qui est le cas des prothèses
pip
mais ceci étant dit pardon non par ceux
ci étaient ceci étant dit bon je crois
que notre notre objectif annoncé de
faire un certain nombre de propositions
dans ce sens nous avons on a élargi la
médecine esthétique parce que ven là
aussi on savait qu'il y avait un
problème
donc on va corriger tout ceci on a
plusieurs tables rondes et en arabe on a
eu beaucoup de pommes beaucoup de monde
qui est venu jusqu'ici on ira aux états
unis pour vérifier un certain nombre de
choses et dans les pays du nord pour les
registre parce que ça c'est très
important
1 et il y en a pas en france et ça c'est
quelque chose de très important
notamment pour les prothèses mais le
problème c'est la sécurité c'est que les
gens c'est à la fois la sécurité du
malade et puis aussi la sécurité des
pratiquants bien sûr et ce que bon après
tout comment ils ont fait pour choisir
leurs prothèses
voilà peut-être la meilleure propagande
ou la connaissance avec des confrères
aussi ou là mais il s'avère du brévent
et certaines prothèses sont défaillantes
se fait par les prothèses de hanche ou
donc voilà le voilà le problème
ce c'est ce que nous essayons de sérier
nous c'est à dire ce problème là bon on
sait que la médecine stick ya un
problème il ya un problème avec les
esthéticiennes on a vu tout à l'heure
les esthéticiennes sont de bonne foi
parfaite blanche comme
plus blanc que moi tu meurs mais ne
parlons pas des dentistes parce qu'on va
pas recommencer
voilà les médecins et les dentistes si
vous continuez comme ça et c'est la
plainte au à l'europe
il ya une petite chose que les dentistes
vous en passerez pas de faire le
nasogéniens xl je ne connais que 200 kg
faux bond mais ceci aura pas rentrer
dans des querelles de bien sûr mais
c'est pas à date que rennes deux
boutiques nous intéresse pas ce qui nous
intéresse et de ses devoirs
à partir de quoi un acte tout peut-être
médical ou accrédité par une structure
qui soient universitaires et médicales
c'est ça et celui que hélas c'était une
question d'ailleurs que je m'apprêtais à
vous poser quelles sont vos
recommandations pour l'encadrement des
actes à visée esthétique qualifié de non
médicaux exemple mobilisation par lui
dire mauvais exemple mauvais exemple
c'est un mauvais exemple aux médicaments
les exemples les sites à sienne le
revendique tout à l'heure elles ont été
condamnées sans faire de polémique sans
essai de l'exercice illégal de la
médecine ils ont été condamnés à
plusieurs reprises pour ses exercices
pratiques
allez la boutique c'est le problème
c'est le problème du législateur qu'est
ce que vous faites conseil de l'ordre
ces législateurs ces législateurs c'est
toujours pareil c'est le problème de la
des matériels de la classification des
matériels si on fait un peu d'
historique puisque c'est un exemple vous
avez pris concernant les lampes flash
les lampes flash sont apparues après
après les lasers et au départ tous les
lasers avait été classé comme matériel
classe 4 c'est à dire qu'ils avaient
uniquement par un médecin ces lampes
flash au tout départ avait très peu de
puissance était pas très performante et
donc personne s'y est trop intéressé
elles ont pris en puissance et le
problème actuel ça peut être aussi la
naissance de nouveaux matériels et c'est
nouveau ce nouveau matériel peuvent
exactement poser le même problème pour
le futur dont les dérives habituelles
donc il ya quand même un arrêté de 1962
qui précise aux esthéticiennes que ce
sont autorisés pour l'épilation la pince
et la cire et c'est encore cet arrêté
qui est en vigueur
donc à partir du moment où elles feront
acte autre que cela elles seront en
exercice illégal de la médecine c'est le
cas c'est le cas quand elle utilise la
plage deuxièmement les lampes flash sont
absolument même beaucoup plus dangereuse
en effet secondaire qu'un laser beaucoup
plus non seulement ça peut brûler mais
en plus il faut faire un diagnostic
il ya une perte de chance pour le
patient parce que lorsqu'on a un
problème de pilosité
il ya quand même un diagnostic affecté
music médical s'il n'y a pas une cause
médicale à cette hyper pilosité c'est
qu'elles ne savent pas faire ce qu'elles
ne savent pas faire et en plus de
d'envoyer un rayonnement non c'est par
monsieur annoncé par monsieur
l'hyperandrogénisme n'est pas rare et
les parents d'origine n'est pas rare et
en dehors en dehors de cela les lampes
flash permettent aussi de traiter pas
seulement le poil puisque le principe
d'une lampe flash c'est un spectre plus
large qu'un laser et il n'est pas
possible de brider les machines n'est
pas possible de réguler machines elles
peuvent traiter des tâches al traite de
la couperose traiter une tâche une tâche
à votre peau ça peut être un cancer de
la peau donc il ya nécessité d'un
diagnostic avant d'envoyer un
rayonnement pour destruction d'une
lésion cutanée
je vous rappelle que c'est quand même
une destruction de lésions cutanées un
cancer de la peau à une tâche à peine un
mélanome un mélanome statut non mais ho
prêcher des convaincus
faire il ya suffisamment enfer pour
performer nos techniques chacun dans son
métier je pense que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut que les gens comprennent les choses
bon donc j'ai compris que on restait
dans le nom médical et n'utilisait pas
l'appareillage qui normalement doit être
appuyée par des médecins
encore faudra t-il précisé monsieur que
bien préciser la catégorie d'appareils
de là il ya un flou aussi on ne sait
plus haut où c'est que ça commence
le problème c'est de définir des
rayonnements électromagnétiques en fait
de définir de cette façon là ces
rayonnements électromagnétiques
parce que si vous définissez des
catégories d'appareils laser etc
vous serez toujours confronté au bout de
six mois et vous serez toujours en
retard avec la technologie qui arrivent
et je ne parle pas des appareils qui
sont en vente libre sur internet on
magasin bon à la limite aussi bon mais
les uv les uv on a fait une hésitation
qui est contraignante
après a posteriori les uv vous avez une
publication de la mayo clinic récemment
la publication d'un maillot qu'unique 1
montre bien
l'incidence des du bronzage dans une
population qu'ils ont suivis sur à peu
près 20 à 30 ans du population
adolescente sur l'augmentation des
cancers de la peau d'âne au nombre de
vrais avec des pratiques avec des
pratiques effectivement vous allez
retrouver bien sûr mais c'est fort
dommage en dommages en tant que père
battlelog en pathologie tout à fait tout
à fait
ce geste est ici n utilise que les que
le grand public utilisent et en fait on
ne connaît pas je pense que tous ces
procédés physiques
pour l'instant on est quand même dans un
flou dans les faits secondaires à risque
alors je me pose est si vous n'avez pas
d'autres questions en fait d'autres
réponses ma dernière question
moncton peu différente seriez vous
favorable à la mise en place d'un
mécanisme d'indemnisation des accidents
médicaux sans faute je parle de l'aléa
lié à un acte de médecine esthétique
c'est de la médecine
c'est un acte de médecine moi je vous
parle en tant que médecin expert c'est
de la médecine donc surtout à la
médecine esthétique d'un meeting
cardiologique
houda chirurgie c'est au même titre le
médecin le médecin n'a pas commis de
faute oui aussi au civil peut pas dire
si si si c'est comme de la médecine
c'est un métier c'est pareil ce même
niveau
en d'autres termes le médecin n'a pas
commis de faute et ce printemps il ya
préjudice n'est pas normal que le
patient ou plaignants ne soit pas
indemnisé donc c'est la loi kouchner va
coincer 2004 d'autres les normal que les
gens soient indemnisés soit par les
assurances privées
si vous avez un dfp inférieure à 25% 24
soit par l'oniam solidarité nationale
sis au delà quoi ça vous paraît tout à
fait normal donc finalement comme
généralement ce sont des petits
préjudice qui n'entend pas l'avis du
patient c'est plus discutable ce moment
là ce sera souvent des déficits
fonctionnels permanente inférieure à 25%
donc sur grand charge par les assurances
privées et non pas par l'oniam jouer non
je vais faire deux observations
concernant la sinistralité en médecine
esthétique elle est très faible
elle est 20 fois donc ça c'est les
statistiques des grandes compagnies
d'assurances qu'on a amassé ça fait là
médicale de france elles sont vingt fois
inférieur par rapport aux actes
chirurgicaux donc das est déjà le
premier point puisque les chirurgiens
une surprime comme les gynécologues les
obstacles comme les obstétriciens
on voit pas pourquoi nos une surprime
d'autre part on paie déjà nous une prime
d'assurance dix fois supérieure si vous
voulez à peu près à celle d'un médecin
généraliste
donc c'est pour vous dire que déjà
compte tenu de ses deux premières
observations on voit pas l'intérêt d'une
surprime notant qu'il existe
effectivement combien l'a souligné le
professeur dubreuil l'oniam et les crc à
partir du moment où la validité et
l'intégrité psychique ou physique
dépasse 24%
donc on est non mais on est on est
opposé effectivement ce qui fait une
surprise mais on la paye déjà au travers
sur une notre cotisation d'assurance
est-ce que vous avez l'un ou l'autre les
uns ou les autres quelque chose à
rajouter à propos des matériels dont je
viens de parler radiofréquences
ultrasons qui sont vendus comme ça dans
le commerce sera pas un contrôle à faire
parce que c'était des gens qui font
l'auto usage personnel qui vont faire un
cancer de la peau des raps et
dermatologues qui m'a filé le cancer
parce qu'il a fait cela et c c'est le
prochain règlement de gens sérieux
appareils on en parlera aussi mais bon
ça dépend plus de nous ça c'est c'est
une réglementation commerciale alors que
vous savez sur des sites n'est pas posé
la question sur l'accréditation c'est
exprès attendait parlait pas je voulais
simplement bon terme de cette audition
dire que la volonté du conseil national
de l'ordre des médecins s'est vraiment
viser la sécurité et la qualité nous
l'avons déjà dit et de ne pas
marginaliser cette médecine
sinon on enfile médecine de déviation
les marginalise c'est une médecine à
part entière avec un acte médical à part
entière un dossier médical comme nous
l'avons vu qui nécessite une formation
de type universitaire avant tout c'est
une médecine qui a les mêmes obligations
niveau du dossier et aussi de
l'assurance comme nous venons de le voir
je pense que la médecine esthétique doit
être un complément d'exercice à une
spécialité déjà existantes dermatologie
cpr e médecine générale ou rhumatologue
mais ça doit rester un acte est une
activité médicale à part entière
formation continue devraient être
obligatoires
oui mais elle devrait elle se revoit et
est maintenant c'est légal des pc la
formation médicale continue et
obligatoire des pc avec le loger des pc
tout intérêt tout est organisé
actuellement tout organisé et sur sur
l'accréditation mais ce que ces
volontaires sur un ton monta sur
l'accréditation la cinquième question
sur la validation si nous serions
favorables
non mais j'ai considéré que la cinquième
question vous y avez répondu au gril des
questions
maintenant si vous voulez lire et parce
que je me suis adressé un petit peu au
sujet mais c'est quelque chose que
j'avais proposé aux conseillers thuiller
au ministère et qui apparemment n'a pas
été retenu c'était effectivement la
procédure d'accréditation pour les
médecins ses tics
mais sa nécessité d'abord comme vous le
savez une modification de la loi puisque
la loi du 13 août 2004 ne permet qu'aux
médecins et l'équipe médicale d'une même
spécialité qui exercent dans un
établissement de santé
donc ça me veut ça obligerait si vous
voulez pour accréditer les médecins
esthétiques en l'occurrence déjà une
modification législative
donc c'est vrai que c'était un peu
compliqué mais je vais mettre en place
une accréditation des médecins je veux
dire pourquoi je n'ai pas posé parce que
j'ai constaté
j'ai considéré d'après les réponses qui
avait été fait sur la formation et sur
les choses comme ceux ci et c'était
inutile
c'était effectivement législativement un
problème et puis on puisse c'est encore
encore quelque chose de plus je crois
qu'il faut pas non plus à a assommé les
d'être ensemble des médecins avec vont à
partir du moment où ils ont fait ce que
je pense souvent que vous êtes vous me
donnerez d'autres éléments mais je pense
qu'à partir du mans le médecin est formé
dans un
c'est dans un système de vérification
universitaire votre mais où compétences
m'a fait quelque chose qui fait que la
formation existe qu'il peut y avoir de
la formation continue chez 2k héros
parce que vraiment ça évolue tous à
celui qui continue passe fort mais c'est
comme en médecine qu'elle soit général
ou non il faut il faisait défaut
d'information
donc j'ai pensé que c'était pas
nécessaire de faire de l'accréditation
et ces personnes je n'ai pas posé la
question
c'est compliqué en plus à mettre en
place et autant pas crédité plus
facilement les structures vérifier si
vous voulez l'environnement dans lequel
travaillent les médecins ça c'est
éventuellement faisable c'est plus
réaliste et plus pragmatique et sa part
le biais des sais pas si vous êtes au
courant la norme afnor l'acquis projet
de norme afnor c'est un peu facile à gaz
on l'avait dit qu'on dirait un mot sur
le projet de décret vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que effectivement il ya du flou
tout ça et bien écoutez si vous poussez
à faire adopter ce projet de décret
avant les élections je pense qu'il aura
plus du tout de flou parce que il est
exactement bien défini quels sont les
actes des médecins tout est bien défini
quels sont les équivalences attendre des
gens qui ont été formés avant la
publication du décret par la voie
universitaire et quelle est la formation
prévue dans les années à venir donc
vraiment de tout sera beaucoup plus
clair grâce à ce projet de décret qui
emporte unanimité de tout le temps dans
sa les élections mais avant les
élections et aucune d'être un
gouvernement quel qu'il soit ne prendra
ce type de décret ne serait ce que vous
repassez mètres les 45 minutes dentiste
ados avoir les élections donc je suis
d'accord avec vous ce projet ce projet
me conviennent tout à fait or il ya
peut-être quelques examens de nom à
faire ils ont pour mettre un peu d'huile
dans les rouages parce que c'est pas non
plus utile d'opposer obligatoirement les
gens les uns aux autres même dans des
professions similaires
par opposition à cette esthétique
chirurgicaux par rapport à tous les
actes esthétiques qui ne sont ni
médicaux ou chirurgicaux
parce que de parer toujours de médecine
esthétique ça rentre dans une opposition
en fait ça permet de globaliser les
choses et de bien séparer de biens sein
des dents dans cette les professions
différentes bien mais je crois que il ya
plus de cas la crainte que vous avez un
dentiste un dentiste travail à
l'intérieur d'une lincoln je vois pas
comment il peut travailler d'un coup sûr
la faut alors les médecins esthéticiens
et les dermatos se sont mis d'accord au
bout de 25 ans pourquoi ce qu'il faut
miser
ils estiment eux que ya un article qui
dit où est le problème
le maxillaire et c'est ici à la
continuité ou non non non et titi su je
connais par coeur l'article et ses
tissus à tenon mais il ya 2,6 en calcin
problème de sémantique et ses tissus à
tence rapporte un max hilaire et non pas
à la cavité buccale
il ya eu là je vous ferez des lois
je serai que les problèmes de simoncelli
sens de l'intrigué parfois même sévit
depuis quelques temps depuis quelques
temps j'ai mis mon nom est un peu dans
des lois par deux pas ma fonction de
président du syndicat effectivement ça
c'est complexe
vous vous accordez de bien écouter nous
reste à vous remercier de participation
cette audition qui a été très riche en
informations très intéressantes
voilà pour les travaux de la mission
commune d'information du sénat sur les
dispositifs médicaux implantables pour
revoir cette table ronde consacrée à la
médecine esthétique notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
je vous retrouve cet après midi à 16h30
pour la suite des travaux parlementaires
très belle journée à tous